a woman is petitioning the government to
change its workplace laws after she was
sent home without pay for refusing to
wear high heels in the office Nicola
thought was employed by an agency to
work as a receptionist at PwC's London
office and as of a few moments ago more
than 46,000 people have signed up to
Nicolas petition on the UK Parliament
website she told us more about what
happened a little earlier I turned up on
site as I normally would to a new job
and I was wearing my flat shoes and they
gave me the uniform that they expected
me to wear that day at which point the
supervisor said that I wasn't allowed to
go out and work that day because I was
wearing flat shoes she offered for me to
go and buy a pair of heels from the shop
in which case they'd let me work but I
refused you on principle therefore was
sent home without pay I turned and said
pointed to a male colleague who stood
next to me I said he's wearing flat
smart shoes you're not sending him home
I feel like this is a sex and a break
sorry a sex discrimination issue and I
was left up well high heels have also
been at the centre of the diversity
debate in the film industry
organizations of the Cannes Film
Festival were criticised last year after
apparently banning women from wearing
flat shoes on the red carpet and joining
us from the French resort is Claire fins
who's director of programming and
acquisitions at picturehouse cinemas and
here in the studio with us is Hirini a
younger a barrister who specializes in
discrimination and employment law hurry
Nia anger let's just start with you and
at the case of Nicola Thorpe is it legal
for a company to insist that she wore
wears high heels to work well it's
lawful for a company to have a dress
code for example to say to receptionists
we expect you to look smart and it's
also lawful for it to be different from
men and women so for example there was a
case a couple of years ago about a man
who said he didn't want to be made to
wear a shirt and a tie because female
colleagues weren't and the fact of the
matter is in this country we do have a
lot of gender norms about what's normal
dress for men normal dress for women and
so at the moment the law says it is okay
for an employer to say
we've got different clothes for men and
different clothes for women in and some
things in most cases a biological
difference for example you might have
rules about facial hair how long your
beards could be that just applies to man
and so in this case you might there may
be rules about shoes for example where
it's lawful to have different rules for
men and different rules for women but in
terms of whether or not this was lawful
I think it depends on the job for
example if you're a dancer in a West End
show or if you're a model in you're
looking pretty or even sexy might be
part of what you're getting paid for and
in that case it might be lawful for the
employer to say no we require all our
dancers to wear these high-heeled dance
shoes it seems they are your job if
you're wearing a pair exactly apply to a
receptionist
that's the question really and we've not
seen her job description and I haven't
seen you know what shoes she had on or
what shoes she was told to wear but I
think in terms of a business environment
a lot of us struggle to see how wearing
high-heeled shoes is relevant to being a
receptionist a lot of us would struggle
to wear high heels for an entire I mean
that's also very interesting I think
some of us when we were younger with
more fans of high heels and as you get
older and you listen to your podiatrist
you start to realize just how badly if I
say that wearing high heels I probably
get sent home
you laugh at that but actually I you
laugh at that but the laws change so
much and people's understanding has
changed so much in terms of transgender
status and as transgender people acquire
more rights and we should be more
tolerant and eople then we look at these
then looking at these gender specific
dress codes becomes more problem now
this is a petition asking the government
to change the law how could the law be
changed do you think well I don't really
think that the laws at fault I said it's
in so many times it's the way the laws
being interpreted or handled what I
think is really interesting is that pwc
from what we know has been clear to say
oh it's not our dress code
it's the subcontractors and they've said
all we're reviewing it and I think the
subcontractors now also said are we
reviewing it and my view is that may
well review it and decide that it's
longer what it should be